i'm liz clayman i'm chris wallace i'm
maria bartoramo and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday july 7th 2021 i'm lisa brady
president biden says kovit is on the run
but he's urging the unvaccinated to
think twice about
virus variants which are also keeping
the mask debate alive the risk will
never be zero
and if our task is to eliminate kovid
we're gonna be in this situation forever
i'm dave anthony
he's letting us into his world jesse
waters has a new book
the co-host of the five knows he's a
liberal lightning rod
people that are writing about me don't
like me very much so if you google me
probably the most unflattering things
will come up
um and and i'm okay with that because
i'm secure with who i am and i know the
truth
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the fight against kovid is not over
president biden emphasizing that during
a covet update on tuesday
even as he praises u.s progress on
vaccinations
more than 182 million americans have
received at least one shot
including nearly 90 percent of seniors
and 70 percent of adults over the age of
27. but it remains a tougher sell with
younger adults
and in some states especially in parts
of the south so the white house kova
task force is surging response teams
in communities with low vaccination
rates expanding mobile clinics and
door-to-door campaigns
and sending more vaccine to local
practitioners right now
as i speak to you millions of americans
are still unvaccinated
and unprotected and because of that
their communities are at risk their
friends are at risk the people that they
care about are at risk
this as public health officials track
more contagious strains of covid
especially the delta variant already
dominant in some countries and in parts
of the u.s
the world health organization also
recently highlighting the lambda variant
first found about a year ago in peru but
so far existing vaccines appear to
provide
strong protection from variants and not
all health officials
are sounding the alarm it's uh look
there's definitely some fear mongering
going out there to manipulate
the public by suggesting the variants
are
going to be you know come back with a
vengeance dr marty mccary is a professor
of surgery and health policy at the
johns hopkins school of medicine
a fox news medical contributor and
author of the price we pay
the reality is every coveted infection
is with a variant
variants constitute every virus that's
out there right now we don't have the
original strain still circulating
and because it's a variant just means it
may be more contagious
so the risk to an everyday american out
there first of all if you're
immunized you're pretty well protected
at least against the serious
complications of
dying or serious illness so you can feel
good if you've got vaccinated about
these
new variants like the delta variant and
lambda variant
you shouldn't worry about them if you've
got natural immunity for sure
you don't need to worry about these new
variants if you're unvaccinated it means
you're more likely to get it because
it's more contagious but
the background level of infection is so
low
that's a factor in your likelihood of
getting it right now we've got about
1 20th the number of cases on a daily
basis as we did just six months ago
so there's not as much virus in society
right now
given the spread of the variants though
because as you say they can be more
contagious
even though if you're vaccinated you may
not have
big you know risks from them in terms of
illness and death
but they do tend to be more contagious
so we are we all at greater risk you
know longer term
if more people aren't vaccinated
so the delta variant is about 40
more transmissible more contagious you
can think of it as
more sticky and so it's not going to
somehow
find you if you're at home by yourself
and seep through the vent
but it does mean if you have a brief
interaction with somebody
indoors the likelihood of getting it
from somebody infected
is going to be a little higher the folks
that should be aware of this
are those who are what we call
susceptible or non-immune
those who um are not vaccinated
and don't have natural infection and by
the way that's mostly the young people
now at the same time there's no evidence
that either the
delta variant or lambda variant or alpha
or any of the variants
have been more deadly so the the risk
to somebody who's young and healthy is
still comparable to seasonal flu
even though it's got a scary sounding
name like delta variant
what advice would you give at this point
for children or i should say to the
parents of children
especially if they're not old enough to
get vaccinated yet
the group in america i'm most concerned
about are older americans or
americans with a morbid condition like
obesity
who are still susceptible that is
they're not immune kids
still remain a very inefficient
transmitter of the infection and when
they get the infection
they tend to get a much lower grade
infection
when i ask people in america when they
um when i chat with them about covid
what's the rate of a
child being hospitalized with covid in
america
they give me all these sort of high
numbers the reality is
the rate today is 2 per million that's
the population incidence
of a child being hospitalized for covid
among children i ask people sometimes
how many
kids do you think have died of covid
during the entire u.s pandemic the last
year and a half
i get all kinds of different answers
total number of kids under 18 who have
died from covet for the whole pandemic
326 as reported by the cdc but that
could have been causal
or incidental that is covid could have
just been simply
tested for when they came to the
hospital for a broken arm
or it could have been the reason that
they came to the hospital i'm not
suggesting we blow it off but when
parents are trying to make a calculation
on the vaccine for example in a 13 year
old
a couple principles number one if the
kid is healthy
it's very hard for this virus to hurt
them if the kid has a chronic condition
like the kid is obese those are the kids
that have
much worse skewed outcomes and the kids
where i would say the vaccine is
really important also folks that don't
feel comfortable with the standard
two dose vaccine because there have been
a cluster
of heart complications with the second
dose i tell them it's reasonable to do
one dose
in somebody who may be concerned about
those complications
right and we should note there's an
investigation of those complications and
that's it's not a proven
link at this point to the vaccine
but what about younger children who not
or they're not old enough to get
vaccinated
is that the group that should really
focus on masking up
at this point so if um there was a
risk to their health then i would say
maybe that makes sense
the the issue is that for a healthy kid
as we've always said and as the data
have now affirmed
it's very hard for covid to hurt a
person young
and healthy the risk is then that they
could transmit it even unknowingly
to somebody who is high risk or even an
adult could be a classmate who's high
risk
or an adult and that's where i think we
leave it to
communities at their own individual
discretion and i don't say that
really to shirk answering the question i
say that because
there's a different level of background
risk in the community
depending on the community some
communities united states
have almost no covet there's almost no
covet in the schools and the in the
young groups
other communities have had outbreaks in
sporting events
with teenagers and we need to respond
quickly when there's an outbreak
and take significant mitigation even
canceling school or canceling sporting
events
for a number of weeks we've done that
with influenza for years when there's
been an outbreak
but just to provide some context
as many as 326 kids have died of covets
for all the pandemic 500 kids a year
die from the common cold a virus called
rsv
so it's always good to practice good
hygiene
but at the same time the perception of
risk i think is distorted
right now in the united states what does
this mean then
for schools and workplaces preparing for
students and workers returning
especially as we look ahead to the start
of the next school year
not that far off well that's what i
think a lot of people are asking right
now
and the risk will never be zero and if
our task is to eliminate covid
we're going to be in this situation
forever in perpetuity
um the reality is if the risk
and then by the way as doctors we don't
tell people that something is safe
or not safe and at least not in my field
of of um
of surgery what we tell them is that the
risks are
low extremely low near
zero or manageable and so we let them
make the decisions and
right now that level of risk is pretty
apparent in communities there's
parts of the united states like areas of
missouri where they're having some
outbreaks now
it's probably pockets of those who are
not immune
and it's the delta variant which is more
contagious
they need to be careful they need to
almost if you will go backwards in time
maybe mask up if they've taken their
masks off
and they're not immune other parts of
the country
can feel really good i mean connecticut
parts of
new mexico parts of california i mean
it is almost as low as it will get right
now and i think they should live a
normal life
in addition to the start of the new
school year the next flu season
is also really right around the corner
do you think protocols for that
should be any different this year
especially
in light of you know more covet strains
you know this is the time where normally
we start educating people on the flu
vaccine for the seasonal flu
and we'll start seeing cases in
september or october
but we may see what we saw last year and
that is because people are so careful
and generally exercising great hygiene
that we might see in almost you know
near elimination of the flu of the
typical flu season you know the country
has been oddly complacent about the
number of flu deaths each year
which affect kids and adults it's
heavily skewed towards older people
but it's 30 to 80 000 people a year die
from seasonal flu and last year what we
saw is because people were taking good
hygiene precautions for covid even if
they were excessive at times
it really did halt the flu and so it's
probably never going to be acceptable
again
to show up at the office coughing and
sneezing and slobbering right next to
somebody
hopefully we've learned one silver
lining from this pandemic is we've
learned that
masks are important when somebody is
either exposed
concerned high risk or has symptoms and
i'd really
emphasize the last point if somebody is
coughing
for every season from here on out they
should have the courtesy of wearing a
mask rather than
you know spraying that part particulate
in a public area
it seems like in general at least from
your take
were we've arrived at a point in this
pandemic
um that really a lot is
location location location and and
individual
um factors individual
decision making yeah that's right i mean
the reality is
covid is never going to go away lisa
we're going to be dealing with this for
our entire lifetime
and given the nature of its transmission
which is often asymptomatic
it's going to circulate at very low
levels the the good news is
we can feel really good about immunity
if you've got immunity from
vaccination or natural immunity right
now it looks like
you're pretty much bulletproof now
nothing's perfect
but it looks like 99.9 plus of the time
you really don't have to worry about
serious illness if you're
immune so for those who are not immune
i'd encourage them to come on over and
join the immune side
and at the same time on a policy level
as much as i'm pro-vaccine
i don't think society can wait for every
single
walking living human being to get the
vaccine i think we need to encourage it
and at the same time move on those who
choose not to get
vaccinated do so at their own individual
risk
and that risk is going to stay or stick
around it's not going to go away
and i think it's important for people to
know that fox news medical contributor
dr
marty mccary thank you as always for
your time
good to be with you lisa thank you
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
you can watch him on tv six days a week
it's five o'clock in new york city and
this is the five a show jesse waters
co-hosts monday through friday on fox
news channel with dana perino and greg
gutfeld
he has his own show saturday nights at 8
p.m eastern
welcome to waters world i'm jesse waters
we're halfway through 2021 and one thing
is clear
it's the year of cancel culture the woke
mob is coming for you and they're never
satisfied
well now jesse has something new for you
to read
a book out this week how i
saved the world i used a very
arrogant title to mask my many
insecurities so
now we all know and you know i thought
it's interesting you you don't put a lot
of uh
flattering blurbs on this either so
one of the things every author does is
they go around sucking up to
people who are famous and asking them if
they could write a blurb for the back of
the book
right and everybody writes fake nice
things about whoever asks them
and then they owe them a favor i decided
not to go that route
um because i don't like favors in
general so i just put a bunch of things
people wrote about me and the media
that are glowing right glowing so
yes jesse waters is officially out of
control the washington post
does jessie waters have the most
punchable face in america the answer is
obviously yes the daily beast and keep
this guy
off tv mayor bill de blasio probably the
only thing he has right
all good friends of yours yes yes so how
does how i save the world become a book
like how how did you
save the world well i needed to write a
book because i needed the money
dave okay and that is the honest answer
but i'd gotten to a place in my life
where
things were calm i'd gotten remarried
and
moved and gotten to a nice place
professionally where i had the time
to to write it and reflect on my career
and and
tell some stories that people i thought
would
laugh at and uh i just happened to time
it during the pandemic so i started
writing and then the pandemic hit
and then i had no excuse yeah i had i
had nothing else to do
you know i had to write the book so i i
did it during the pandemic and uh
and we hope everybody goes out and gets
it because the people that have read it
already who got an advanced copy
uh love it they they said they left
their tails off so i'm really happy
about that
i did find it interesting you started
right away in your introduction
with you being attacked yes because as
you know i am always the victim
in any situation of course and i was
attacked on a subway
by a guy who confused me with pete
except so he said
he said are you the guy that doesn't
wash his hands i said no i'm not pete
except i'm jesse
waters and uh yeah i talk about
in the book about how you know there's a
lot of hostility
on the streets especially in manhattan
and
i'm walking around manhattan as a fox
news guy so
i'm often confronted by
loving fans who say i love you jesse
let's take a selfie or
f you nazi and you got to shower a beer
in the subway
i did and uh it was a wide mouth can
tall boy so this was like a fire hose
and so i had to decide how i was going
to react to that uh
did i turn the other cheek like a quaker
or did i
did i react with force and and people
can read the book and find out yeah how
that shook out
i did like uh you put google me
i'd hate me too if only i saw myself
through a liberal prism
well listen we live in and you know this
dave in
a media landscape that's probably 90
percent
liberal so as a conservative
on fox news all the press i get
is liberal press i don't get glowing
pieces i don't get full
spreads on time magazine and i don't get
that
i get i get hateful takedown pieces
so people that are writing about me
don't like me very much
so if you google me probably the most
unflattering things will come up um and
and i'm okay with that
because i'm secure at who i am and i
know the truth to be fair and balanced
uh president obama used to say hey
if i watched fox news i wouldn't vote
for me either
that's true right so but not you know if
95
of the media is not fox it's not even 50
so you know we're just looking for
fairness and balance over here
a lot of people will recall you and your
work with bill o'reilly and you wrote
some glowing things about him
uh in in the book um
you did a lot for him and you also of
course i
used to like watching your waters world
pieces that you did for him when you go
out all over the place and that's a lot
of what this book is right you used to
go all over the place
so yes so bill says
he sent me outside because i was
bothering everybody in the building
and he wanted everybody else outside of
the building to be bothered so one day
he said jesse
i'm going to send you out on the streets
and i'm going to have you ask people
what they know about america and it
turns out they
know very little so i would go and talk
to a younger demographic and quiz people
ask them basic questions about this
country like
you know who won the civil war and
people would say
france and and it was you know you had
to try not to laugh
but it was scary too because you know
you get a population that's so
oblivious they're very easily
manipulated and that's what politicians
and corporate america does they
manipulate an oblivious population and
get away with murder
because no one's paying attention and no
one knows jack
and and part of going out it was also
exposing people but also informing
people because water's world as you know
is an educational
experience there are so many things you
have saved
the great outdoors you've saved the
children yes uh you saved journalism
you've saved hollywood you saved
christmas i didn't realize
well remember the war on christmas we
won
and uh i was a veteran in that war um
and we used to go out and confront
villains who'd
take christmas lights down because they
said i believe great barrington
said that they were contributing to
global warming putting christmas lights
up and
so we'd go down to different towns and
and talk to officials who were banning
candy canes from schools and
things like that so that was just one of
many wars that i thought dave
you remember the war on women i was also
i have the
the scars to prove that obviously i was
on the side of women okay
protecting the women obviously and so
you know and the war on children in a
more serious way we used to go out and
confront
judges who used to give soft sentences
to child sex predators and
we got an initiative started jessica's
law which was
you get 25 years mandatory minimum
for first time rape of a child under 12.
and at the end of that campaign
nationwide campaign i believe 45 states
had passed some version
of jessica's law and that was something
that i was very very proud of to be a
part of
yeah because not only would you go
around like college campuses and
interview people about america you also
would sometimes
follow someone who you guys wanted a
comment from who was refusing a comment
and you would try to get a comment on
camera and that didn't usually go well
was that uncomfortable for you was that
difficult to do yes
but you have to live in that discomfort
you have to own the
discomfort where you are shamelessly
approaching someone in their driveway
even sometimes with their children in
places
even at mcdonald's just going up to
someone like that
and ruining their day but doing it in a
kind of a righteous way because
these people had to be held accountable
for
things that they had done as public
officials where they'd let people off
without punishment um where they had
been a part of a mis
carriage of justice so i you had to
really work yourself up and
kind of carry the emotion of the victim
into that confrontation and
and do right by them and that was
something i learned to do on television
and uh gave me great training for being
on live tv later in the studio
we know al gore created the internet but
you saved it you saved it and and that's
one of your chapters as well
and and it it goes right into how
someone tried to do this to you
so right we used to go around and as you
said
used to confront people i think i
followed al gore into a men's room by
accident
he was uh trying to get away from me and
he walked in somewhere and i realized i
was
following al gore that's not good to a
urinal
and i had i had a moment there i said
this i have to turn her i have to stop
they're just waters has a line he can't
yeah you found a lion i
finally found the line and uh and i
turned around and just waited for him to
leave the bathroom and continue to
confront him
but um i'm sure he had no comment right
right well you know he tried to dodge
and spin but um
yes people did try to turn the tables on
me and they
they'd approach me at my house and my
apartment
and you know i had to deal with that too
and
you know you kind of learned to live in
that world i probably deserved it
um although you know i didn't do
anything really to deserve it
as i mentioned before i am a big victim
in all of this
always the victim and uh so you gotta
learn to be quick on your feet someone
shoves a camera in your face in your
driveway how are you gonna handle it
you know there's a few you can snap like
baldwin
and knock a guy out and that's what they
want that's what we want uh rosie
o'donnell did that to me
when i confronted her at a bookstore
yeah she was at a signing and i asked
her about you said 911 rosie was an
inside job you know what's up with that
and
you know she plays along and then she
has her goons grab my camera and you get
that
you know out of focus you know noise
coming from the camera and it looks very
very confrontational that's what we want
sure when you're out there but you could
also go the other route there was a guy
at merrill lynch
stan o'neal who i think took 165
million golden parachute out of that
company
left everybody else holding the bag
remember during the financial crisis
oh yeah you know i confronted him on the
way to the golf club and he just didn't
say anything
just stone cold silence and that's
probably the best way to handle me
don't say anything let's go to the five
obviously you're a co-host on this show
every monday through friday
10th anniversary week big big week for
you guys very happy about that
uh you know i've only been a part of the
show for four out of the ten years but
the show's been extremely successful at
two o'clock
pacific time if you can believe that
we're you know third
highest rated cable news show in the
country which really speaks to how
authentic we are how funny we are and
how real the show is
and how honest it is and uh we're going
to be celebrating all week so tune in to
the five at five o'clock eastern and
you'll see some
crazy stuff there's going to be a lot of
surprises and i don't even know
is jasper going to show up on the set
you're going to have to watch but there
will be
special guest appearances dana and that
dog right i mean that's it's
it's a love affair it is a love affair
um jasper is
he's maybe we call it the six when
jasper's on
that's fine and everybody loves jasper
the five of course
is at 5 00 p.m monday through friday on
the fox news channel
you can also catch jesse's show waters
world saturday nights fox news 8 p.m
and the brand new book how i saved the
world by jesse waters
now out go pick it up and jesse thanks
for the time thanks so much dave i
appreciate it
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there
about the country and where we're going
subscribe to the ben dominic podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy
benson guy what's on your mind nike
the american athletics wear giant has
two corporate faces
here at home they're very progressive
and woke throwing money at colin
kaepernick and running ads on
progressive
issues that's the face that they want
american consumers to see but in china
they kowtow to the ccp and the regime in
beijing looking the other way or even
standing in solidarity with the regime
on issues ranging from human rights
abuses to the crushing of democracy in
hong kong so while nike seeks brownie
points
from the social justice movement here at
home their supposed values
are often compromised or ignored
entirely in china
why because there's a huge market there
which is extremely lucrative which might
explain why on a recent earnings call
the ceo of nike john donahoe said quote
we are a brand
of china and for china end quote i'd
love to hear him elaborate on that
and reconcile that sentiment with the
way nike portrays itself in the united
states
this is guy benson host of the guy
benson show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon breem host of fox news at
night and author of the new book women
of the bible speak the wisdom of 16
women
and their lessons for today subscribe
now on apple podcast spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes